[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في ظهور النادره
كشف زعيم الكوريه والشماليه عن ابنته
للمره الاولى اثناء تجربه اطلاقه صاروخ في
وقت عادت فيه امريكا نشر القافله
الامريكيه بي وان بي في كوريا الجنوبيه
وكان وجود ابنتي كيم اضافه مفاجاه لعمليه
الاطلاق اذ لم يتم تاكيد وجودها علنا من
قبل ويقول محللون ان ظهورها المفاجئه يثير
احتمالا انتقال اذا زعامه الدوله الشموليه
الى جيلنا رابعا من عائلتكم من جانب هذا
ذكرت وكاله الانباء الرسميه انها كوريا
الشماليه اجره تجربه تطلق صواريخ 17
الملقب الوحش بسببي حجمه الكبير قادر على
حمل رؤوس الحربيه
متعدده بمدى يبلغ نحو ال 15,000 كيلو متر
وانقلت وكاله جون هذا الكوريه الشماليه او
وبيعوا ان صاروخ اطلق من مطر بيونغيانغ
دولي وقطع مسافه 1,000 كلم بمعادلان يقرب
من اربع ثواني لكل كيلومتر وهبط في المياه
الدوليه لبحر الشرق فيما اجرت بيونج عددا
قياسيا من تجارب الصواريخ خلال العام
الجاري واطلقت اكثر من 50 صاروخا ما بين
قصير المدى وبعيد المدام منذ الخامس
والعشرين من سبتمبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بكينا
صحفي نادرانج وانا اهلا بك ومن طوكيو
الصحفي خلدون الازهري اهلا بكمين واسمحالي
ان ابدا من طوكيو معك يا استاذ خلدون امم
مبدئيا ما استوقف البعض هو ليست تجربه
الصاروخيه في حد ذاتها المخيفه كما وصفها
مراقبون ولكن ان تحضر هذه التجربه ابنه
الرئيس رئيس رئيس كوريا الشماليه ما
العلاقه كيف قرات الموضوع هل كما قرا
مراقبين بانه يود دفعها الى الصحافه
السياسيه او هناك قراءات اخرى في ما يخص
هذا الحضور
هو يعتقد انه يريد ان يظهر كرجل العائله
رجل عنده عائله جميله مثلا ابنته وعنده
ايضا ولدين ااه اصغر منهما هي عمرها
تقريبا 12 الى 13 سنه هذا يريد ان يرسل ان
نظره القائل عنه بانه يقتل اقربائه عندما
يهددونه هذا طبعا ليس له اي اهميه على
مجال تسليم السلطه في كوريا الشماليه التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش بشكل عام وهذه العائله
هي رئيس الهرم في القاموس السلطه الكوري
الشمالي لذلك همم لا تاثير سياسي او عسكري
نهائيا على وجود هذه
العائله تكون حاضره همم واضحه ولكن همم
سيد نادر كيف تتابع الصين هذه التجارب همم
يعني تجربه جديده لصواريخ عابره للقارات
طب لقبت بالوحش همم هل هناك قراءه معينه
لهذه التجارب او توضع في اطار تجارب قامت
بها في الواقع من قبل كوريا الشماليه
وتستمر
او التفاهم في شبه الجزيره الكوريه واا
يمكن ان نلاحظ ان كل التجارب الصاروخيه
يعني لا تاتي في كوريا الشماليه لا تاتي
لوحدها فهي دائما
بالتزامن مع مناورات العسكريه الواسعه
النطاق قامت بها الولايات المتحده
وخلفائها همم يمكن ان همم
[موسيقى]
وكذلك همم
بعد كل المدورات العسكريه هناك يعني
الصواريخ من قبل همم
كوريا الشماليه وهذا يعني همم
بان هذه التجارب هي رد على مناورات البنات
المتحده الامريكيه وحلفاءها
طبعا هذا هو يعني
القلق او يمكن ان نقول الاهتمامات الامنيه
الكوريه الشماليه لم تحضر بالاستجابه من
قبل الولايات المتحده وهناك تناقضات بين
الكوريا الشماليه والولايات المتحده وبعد
يعني
رغم كان هناك النيه الاشاره الايجابيه
للدعوه في عام 2018 فلن لم يكن هناك
تحركات الامريكيه يعني
كوريا الشماليه من الاسلحه النوويه فلذلك
بعد ولكن بعد خمس سنوات اربع سنوات يعني
تم استعمالات
المحاولات ايام مناورات عسكريه امريكيه
هناك تعزيز لوجود
العسكريه الامريكيه المنطقه وهذا كلها
يعني يزيد
اللي هي شماليه لاهتماماتها الامنيه همم
استاذ خلدون هل ترك ضيفي بان رساله
الموجهه من كوريا الشماليه تخص الرئاسه
المتحده الامريكيه وحلفائها او ان هذه
الرساله يمكن ان تكون متعدده الجهات
اليابان مثلا يمكن ان تكون معنيه كذلك بها
كثار رساله
اولا الرد على تلك المناورات التصعيديه
الامريكيه الكوريه الشمال الجنوبيه بندار
الامريكيين وايضا شاركت بها اليابان
باضافه الى ذلك اليمن تطور برنامج صاروخيا
جديدا وربما تبدا بتصدير الاسلحه اذا ال-
ال- التوجه العسكري اصبح اكثر وضوحا في ظل
هذا التهديد الكوري بنظر اليابانيين ايضا
يهدف النظام الكوري الشمالي الى اظهار انه
نظام قوي امام شعبي وبالتالي يستتب الامر
للعائله الحاكمه السلاله كريم الموجوده
منذ اربعه اجيال تقريبا والبنت اليوم هي
الجيل الرابع الذي يريد ان يؤكد بان هذا
الوضع في كوريا الشماليه مستمر ربما الى
الابد ايضا يحاول كوريا الشماليه تطوير
تكنولوجيا الصاروخيه وخاصه الصواريخ بعيده
بدا يمكن بسهوله لصواريخ 17 ضرب اليابان
وضرب القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه
اليابان ولكن من الصعب جدا ان تصل الى
الولايات المتحده وعليها رؤوس حربيه همم
يمكن تفجيرها بدقه وتحديد مسارها بدقه
اكبر اذن هذه التكنولوجيه ما زالت تفتقد
اليها كوريا الشماليه وهذه التجارب
الصاروخيه الحاليه تهدف الى تطوير هذه
التكنولوجيا وتحسين كفاءتها لكن العقوبات
ربما تؤثر قليلا على او كثيرا على كوريا
الشماليه في تحقيق هذا الهدف لذلك الدول
ال- ال- في هذه المنطقه من العالم تسير في
طريق مسدود وفي دائره مغلقه همم مجرد
تصعيد عسكري بدون الحديث عن اي حلول
دبلوماسيه ومجرد عدم اهتماما للولايات
المتحده في الواقع في حال هذه الازمه مع
كوريا الشماليه لانها لا تشعر بتهديد
حقيقي لكن الياباني هي التي تشعر بتهديد
حقيقي ايضا ربما الصين لا تريد انهيار
كوريا الشماليه وبالتالي تسمح الى حد ما
بتجاوز العقوبات المفروضه عليها لبقاء
الوضع الكوري اعمامه عليه
نادر من مصلحه الصين الابقاء على كوريا
الشماليه ولكن بحذر
من موقفها فهي تريد
التعزيز الاستقرار والسلام في المنطقه ولا
تريد التسعيد او تغيير كبير في هذا يعني
خاصه في في ما يتعلق بوضع في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
لانه اليوم همم هذه التجارب صاروخيه تضعنا
في همم على ارض مرتبكه همم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تنور اليابان تتعسكر
اكثر فاكثر همم كوريا الشماليه همم
تطلق تجارب لصواريخ همم عابره للقارات
الصين يجب ان تكون معنيه بالموضوع
طبعا طبعا لذلك راينا الصين تدعو الى جميع
الاعتراف الى ضبط النفس وكذلك التجنب من
تسعد الوضع وكذلك السن دائما
مستعده لتقديم جميع دروس الملائمه
لاستئناف المفاوضات والتماسك بحل
الدبلوماسي او حل سياسه لهذه الازمه
وكذلك التماسك في اخلاقه شبه جزيره
الكوريه من الاسلحه النوويه
همم استاذ خلدون قد يقول البعض بان همم
منطق الانتظار او منطق محاوله همم متابعه
هذه التجاربه صاروخيه الى ان يتم يخالف
ذلك منطق يمكن ان لا يكون صالحا لكل زمن
ومكان خاصه وان مع اي انفلات ولو كان صغير
قد تتدهور الامور فبالتالي همم هل نحن في
مرحله خطيره هل نحن في مرحله تشابك خطيره
في مرحله تجارب صاروخيه قد تنبئ بوضع خطر
بالتاكيد هذا التصعيد العسكري اصبح له بعد
اخر جديد وهو البعد الروسي هناك تعاون
كبير ربما بشكل محدود من الناحيه
التكنولوجيه من ناحيه غير التكنولوجيه بين
روسيا وكوريا الشماليه حاليا روسيا تبحث
عن حليف جديد في هذه المنطقه على الاقل
حديث يعادي الغرب الذي بدوره يعادي روسيا
وكوريا الشماليه هي افضل مرشح لذلك وهي
ايد جميع الخطوات الروسيه المتعلقه
باوكرانيا ايضا التكنولوجيات الصاروخيه
الكوريه تعتمد بشكل كبير على روسيا ومعظم
هذه الصواريخ اشترتها الشماليه من روسيا
او حصلت عليها بطريقه غير مباشره مثل
صاروخ الذي كان مصنوعه خلينا نتخيل فقط
ثواني هذا التقارب وتحالف عسكري تتحدث عنه
بين روسيا وكوريا الشماليه كيف سيكون وضع
طبعا اذا حصلت مجابهه عسكريه سيكون الوضع
انهيار نووي في العالم ربما لانه سوف يتم
همم تدخل بهذه الحرب من جميع الاطراف وسوف
تكون اضارها عظيمه وخاصه ربما على كوريا
الجنوبيه التي ستكون مضرر المتضرره
الاقتصاديه الاولى وهذا سوف يؤثر على
الاقتصاد العالم اذا ليس من مصلحه الجميع
هنا حصول حرب ربما تصعيد عسكري ربما سباق
تسلح همم قد تحدث حادثه بسيطه ولكن هذه
القوه العظمى تحاول قدر الامكان عدم توسع
هذه المشابهه تبقى فقط مجرد استعرضيات
عسكريه مثل هذه الصواريخ الكوريه الشماليه
ولكن بنفس الوقت لا يوجد حل اذا همم هناك
نوع من الضياع بين السياسيين في هذه
المنطقه لماذا تبقى هذه الازمه قائمه
لغايه هذه اللحظه وتبقى الصواريخ الكوريه
همم
منتشر في وتسقط في البحر امام اليابان
وامام كوريا الجنوبيه همم سيد همم هذا
السباق نحو التسلح يضع الكل في الواقع حتى
وان كانت الاراده لا تود التوجه نحو هكذا
همم امكانيه ولكن الكل سيصبح من حذره ومن
خوفه ان تفلت الامور يتسلح الصين همم ما
منهج ما منهجيتها ما استراتيجياتها في ذلك
المنطقه
يعني من طاقه منافسه روسيه بين الدول
الكبرى والصين اريد
ان تحقق اهميه همم يعني سلميه او همم
يجب ان يكون همم تنميه مستدامه لكي تحقيق
الازدهار المشتركه همم يكون هناك عسكر
المنطقه لذلك همم
اكثر شهوده
يعني
التمسك باخلاء الشبه جزيره الكوريه اسلحه
النوويه
وترى حسين ان يعني هذا المفتاح همم هذا
الامور هو تتوقف على تحركات الامريكيه لان
الولايات المتحده ومن يعني تعزز وجودها
العسكريه في هذه المنطقه وهذا ما يسبب الى
صباغه تسلحه
والاحاديث المنطقه